just the angle of making that pass here we go
again another mcel he's in with c as he shoots
it just glanced off of brovsky and then the
glass behind quickly played ahead by Alexia
Nik mikolo back hands it around turned over
chance for McMichael kicked out by bosski
Michel cleans up the rebound L Serena from
center ice in not behind the net by Darcy K
had to make one save so far that's where bosski
is so good his legs down low mantha for the SL
it's get
for and mantha cruising down the right side his
head is up all the way looking to the middle of
the ice and mcel it's beyond him so I'm not sure
who he was even going to it wasn't protus and it
wasn't MCM but it banked right off the pants of
the Florida Panthers player there and when we
talked about interior strong bumped it Off the
Wall Wilson charging to get it he's got oetkin
with him as it escapes his grasp he gets it there
oetkin turns SC and it's knocked away in front of
the net Ken mccon who's been around the league
a long time and uh diligent work and will pay
off he's a he's a persistent individual oh she
is yes he is here's kchu throws it out Ean Lars
with a shot and he scores Oliver egman Larson
ties the game for the Florida Panthers what a
r shot that is I mean just a your classic wrist
shot that starts off the heel of your blade and
just rolls out there you hardly H it and one of
the few times where down low from the goal line
out that's one of K Chuck's you know that's
one of his great strengths right there and
this one oh my goodness what a shot this is
just goes over the pad and under the blocker
just beyond the stick and at first I thought
that kachuck was going to wrap that around but
there was nobody there so he makes a smart play
and punts it back to the defenseman lson cousins
on the re-entry flips it in heads after Alexia
L up the wall intercept it toss it the front
barkov turning and shooting but it was blocked
Reinhardt twisting on McMichael his pass shot
score it's barov by the glove hand of keer and
it's a 2-1 lead for the Florida Panthers get
the plus right after barov fired that Puck and
again the position of barov is this reverse went
a ride for the Washington Capitals and it was
alexv that went along the boards but there was
nobody there and again you can see the backend
pass by Reinhardt right here he's got his head
up all the way and even though the Caps are
in good position this is a slick shot here by
barov Larson could chuck that shot into
traffic bouncing Puck cleared away from
the net initially by keer and then a nice
job by Alexi prus to win a battle bring it
ahead short handed mcel and he [Applause] scor
brus and McMichael a short-handed tally to tie
it Florida Panthers were in pretty good
shape it squirts loose and Oliver Ean
Larson was should I stay or should
I go and he pulled back and while
doing so protus did a great job of pushing
that puck to mcel but oh my holy jumping
what a nice play by mcel forehand
backhand up over top of the Fallen
[Applause] goenda now Forman Larson behind the
that CH cut it off stole it TRS it the chance for
stellin denied by camper buny Milano Phillips
both there wrestling for it power play in its
final seconds as Wilson stumbling trying to make a
pass he went down he took Lis maren with him Bucky
nokin and Wilson got up and they scor Sun Milano
tapped it home and the capitals have taken a 3-2
lead this turn of event starts with a what the
Panthers thought was a trip behind the net and
there with the right skate Wilson clearly swings
it and knocks down Lo to ran and the play stays
alive the Panthers went right over to the referee
I believe it was Chris Lee right there but there
you can see the right swing of the leg there to
take down the man and the play is alive and what
a pass by oetkin regardless of a penalty being
one or not it's a great pass by oetkin who's
made three or four unbelievable plays not getting
any scoring chances but he has been the setup man
right there right here right here Wilson on the
right there's his left skate both of them there
are over yeah I mean I I I I I'm saying I'm saying
right there that this is what you're looking at
you're looking at that puck but it's Guided by the
the stick blade but I believe this is offside the
Florida coaches tells is determined that the play
was offside therefore we have no goal please set
847 Sunny Milano Den what would have been his
third goal of the season and now he's in stride
across the line with the shot gets the puck off
the block for mean Larson and set it in front for
strowman it was blocked and then H octel and that
one blocked and now larena with Riley charging
looster to Riley and keer makes the save on the
other end tip of the puck rate there and then the
other way capitals to change their defense pairing
the Panthers to change their defense pairing Riley
gave it away and it's McMichael charging
ahead mantha with him the pass there mantha
[Applause] scores it's the second time for
Anthony manth the capitals have a 3-2 lead
transition it goes the other way they nullified
the icing it looked like the Panthers were on
it right there and again a left hand shot on
the right side it's a disadvantage and it has
been in this game and Riley can't get that over
enough on the backand McMichael makes him pay
with a really smart pass immediately so he brings
mahura to him and then he plays it right over to
Mana Andre kopar sitting on 399 goals and this
one is stolen away here comes Dimitri kulakov on
a breakaway save by keer had he had to have missed
the the part that really had to miss the mark that
he was looking for when it goes right off the
path like that look at that back door more play
for Rodriguez what a feed from Gusta forsling
and the Panthers have tied it [Applause] three
through traffic and the faceoff win by barov and
now he goes to the front of the net and look at
that everyone's preoccupied with the big man in
front of the net forsling find I don't know how
he found him I mean Rodriguez just skates and has
his stick on the ice I mentioned to Rodriguez as
we were starting the third period Brendon I
said boy you got the plus when Nick cousins
did all the work DJ oi hobbling towards the bench
from the Washington Capitals meanwhile Veri the
back hand of the front and a big time stop by
Darcy keer sine for cus he misfired on the pass
a follow through caught for haggy up High play
continues the pinballs around pushed into the
net is the goal tener barski and a penalty
coming up here against the Florida Panthers
fourth overtime game for the capitals it's the
third and here's a chance for barov right in
and he scores it's Reinhard the winner just 15
seconds into [Applause] overtime that didn't
take long and the oh Tom Wilson came out and
there is a little bit of a skirmish near the
Washington Capitals brings it to the forehand
barov what a play off the boards perfectly
executed and here I thought he was going
to go to the back end cuz net off's on the
other side ryanh Hart uses his strong part of
his body protects the puck uses the forehand
right there and then he's able to hoist it he's
got a pretty good tow curve and as he brings it
back that really must help him Elevate that
puck quickly and the goal tender keer right
there he's probably thinking he's going to
go across you can see he was slowly moving
or drifting over and that did open up the high
part of the glove but just an out handing play